So we are now ready to officially and very
safely move on beyond the, if Trump did it,
the impeachment inquiry hearings. I'm unsure
if we are going to have more public hearings
or what the next step will be. We've got the
Thanksgiving holiday coming up. Hopefully
in the next day or two. We will know sort
of the planned trajectory of this entire thing,
but particularly with the testimony on Wednesday
by a EU ambassador Gordon Sundland. As we've
discussed, Trump did it and everyone knew
it. Rudy Giuliani knew what was going on.
Mike Palm PEO knew what was going on. The
national security council knew. It seems John
Bolton may have known it was just very clear.
This was an explorative bribery situation
where Ukraine could get military aid, could
get a meeting with president Trump if they
deliver politically motivated smear investigations
of Joe and Hunter Biden if they are announced
in public press conferences specifically to
help Donald Trump win reelection in 2020 it
happened. We can stop debating that. The real
question now is will Trump get away with it?
There's a really good piece in the Detroit
Metro times about exactly this by Jeffrey
Billman. If the question is, will Trump be
impeached and convicted by the Senate? The
answer is probably not. We know the data.
We know that 62% of Trumpists, no matter what
Trump does, did or could do, we'll never turn
on the guy. If they don't turn on Trump, Republicans
in the Senate won't turn on Trump. If the
question is, will Trump be criminally prosecuted
for anything that he has done, the answer
is unfortunately also probably not, or it
is at least beyond anything we can strategize
around right now. So that very quickly makes
the question of whether Trump will get away
with it. One that we can mostly answer in
the sense that Trump getting away with it
would be Trump getting reelected. We can decide
whether we vote for him or we vote him out
in less than a year.
We are now, you know, 345 350 days away from
the November of 2020 election. We knew from
day one that Donald Trump was corrupt. We
suspected that Republicans would by and large
fall in line and let him do whatever the hell
he wants. This is the latest test and so far
Republicans are failing the test very, very
big time, so it now is up to us. Quite simply,
we might have underestimated or overestimated.
The point is we might have assumed that if
a president behaved in this way, even would
say, you know, it can't happen. That's it.
No more. We were very wrong. If we thought
that add to this, that there has always been
one justice and accountability system for
the rich and the powerful and another justice
system for everybody else. That just adds
to the political nature of all of this. So
I actually think that if there's more hearings,
if there's more evidence presented, good,
we will air it, we will discuss it, we will
integrate it into our broader understanding
of what it is that took place, but we don't
need to keep arguing about whether Donald
Trump did it.
They all did it. It's very clear now, the
issue now is figuring out will there be repercussions,
will the right to the extent that it is participating
in the spin machine, a crisis management as
it is, the fact that will become, will they
succeed in pushing narratives like loosen
Trump called sun Lyndon said, I don't want
a quid pro quo when we should be wondering
as I said yesterday, why is that anything
someone would have to say on the phone if
there is not the belief that maybe there is
a quid pro quo. And of course we learned that
the reason Trump did that was because of the
reports that started coming out that day.
Uh, suggesting that actually there was a quid
pro quo Trump getting on the phone and saying,
I don't want a quid pro quo. Okay. It's like
saying, it's like calling up someone and saying,
listen, I don't want anything to happen to
that lovely little girl of yours.
Okay. I want her to be safe. I don't want
anything to happen to her. You understand
what I mean? Well, unless you might have a
role in her not being safe. Why is this a
phone call that we're having? You have to
interpret Trump's behavior more as a a low
grade mob boss who has the desire but not
so much the intellectual capacity to carry
out a lot of
this stuff. There's a really sad actually
story because it has real victims, but it's
also a story of hypocrisy in politics.